a ubiquitous chemical called bisphenol A
better known as BPA coats the inside of
many food and drink cans this lining is
two micrometers thick less than 1/8 of
the thickness of a human hair it's the
crucial barrier between metal and liquid
that ensures a can of soda will retain
its fizz and flavor because it's cheap
durable and flexible BPA is a key
building block of the plastics we use
but there are significant health
concerns related to BPA a lab at Sherwin
Williams a company better known for
paint has come up with an alternative
BPA has been linked to breast and
prostate cancer and reduce fertility
studies have shown that it mimics the
hormone estrogen
which influences growth and development
and disrupts other endocrine processes
meanwhile in the 2000s the CDC found BPA
in the urine of 93 percent of u.s.
adults tested a public backlash to the
use of BPA has ensued today certain BPA
products are banned in many countries
companies have sought a good replacement
for BPA as a can liner but have
struggled vinyls and acrylics have
shorter shelf lives or require more
coatings some other bisphenol come with
the same concerns as BPA but researchers
at Sherwin Williams came up with an idea
what if they could stick with a
bisphenol but find one that wasn't an
endocrine disruptor like BPA company
scientists started out with a computer
program it screened hundreds of
different bisphenol x'
searching for molecular structures that
appeared unlikely to bind with the
body's estrogen receptors the team found
a promising molecule tetramethyl
bisphenol f TM BPF a rarely used
chemical once considered for helping
build electronic circuit boards research
suggests that one of the advantages of
TM BPF is that it doesn't leak from can
linings into drinks like BPA does next
Sherwin Williams wanted proof that the
chemical was benign the company wanted
to establish the molecule safety and
protect its research investment so the
developers decided that they should let
outside scientists and consumer
advocates in on the process the lab
reached out to Anna so tow and
endocrinologists well-known for raising
concerns about ppas health effects she
put the chemical through a battery of
tests her lab found that TM BPF didn't
activate estrogen receptors or spur
growth of breast cancer cells and didn't
affect several genes that respond to
estrogen sure when Williams has taken a
hands-off approach so that Soto could
study the chemical however she saw fit
this has added legitimacy to the
research in the eyes of the broader
community another scientist reviewed
test data and organ samples and
concluded that TM BPF doesn't seem to
affect the thyroid system but it wasn't
all good news one scientists found that
TM BPF might blunt the effect of
estrogen on test cells and that a
polymer made from the molecule might
have similar effects on testosterone
however a lead researcher in the study
said the findings weren't conclusive and
could be specific to these cells
environmentalists are cautiously
encouraged about TM BPF but they aren't
assured that it is safer than other
options something as complex as the
endocrine system has made a definitive
safety screening out of
reach so far still other scientists are
working on more tests and
sherwin-williams is preparing to launch
a new study to answer some of the
remaining questions meanwhile the
company has already started selling a TM
BPF based can coating branded as v70 the
company says that since 2017 its product
has been used on 22 billion cans still a
modest fraction of the estimated 350
billion cans produced each year
worldwide regardless of public health
concerns the bottom line might be what
determines the adoption of these 70 it's
currently twice the price of bpa though
company officials say this is comparable
to other non bpa linings it remains to
be seen whether or not both industry and
consumer groups will ultimately deem the
chemical to be safer either way the
price tag could keep this BPA
alternative from becoming as popular as
BPA
you
[Music]